tous
[Musique]
ouais
raconte andra compliqué et puis deuxième
à dire quand il va de préfon mon staff
d'être très malheureux à vous etes
aujourd'hui mon chrono grand yaka ne
veut pas travailler institut sac elle
celle vers je suis je suis accablé je
suis fondu un peu d air frais me ferait
du bien
une encore les données d'entreprise
rappeur mais je ne peux pas je dois
porter lompret du gringue à 15 juin peut
pas raser complètement éventail importe
l'ombrelle au grand yaka et toi dans ton
rêve brisé rappeur vraiment mort qui tue
mais chitti d'espérer et et tu me donnes
deux trois ans de décrocher un précieux
mais je ne laissais pas sûr moins
abondante arias tu me legault noir tout
à l'heure quand tu feras précis d'accord
est bien un produit tu auras ki-duk
franchement en attendant les trois plans
allons porter l'ombre l ogre en a pas
mon grand lapin n'emporte l'ombrelle
parce que mon chat est obligé de se
retrouver tout le monde dort ici ne vous
dérangez pas pour moi ce que vous voulez
faire de cette encombré l'ombre en
annonce de cet encombrant tomberait de
belleville et c'est un nombril comme ça
quand ils te réveilleras il ne me
dérangera pas mignon quand il ose on
dirait un vieux débat
la voici dans l'ombre mbudi agréable bon
opérateurs ont mal terminé
et à présent devraient de la mémé croise
ben amos cas pour les et bien gagné deux
enfants c'est une beau la terre et la
monte à mon cas c'est toujours à ces
petites us
je viens sur frais mais croit fort ils
n'auront pas tu fais là pour d'oreille
la famille d'un croit femme tu sais tu
m'as pas se demande donc pas dis le moi
tout va bien donc en embuscade roi momo
la porte attention un tel pas au moment
où il lui donner de la tête aux pieds
malheureux pas loin
ils vont sortir de là tu fous de tout
mettre au grand froid en plaindre
opération
heureusement commencent à arriver à
temps
il était moins 20 au dessous de zéro tu
me donnes sûr avec tout dagar maintenant
il faut que je fasse fondre cette glace
fond
un bon feu de bois et thomas fondre
comme une pub est voilà la potel allumée
faisait pas de me mettre tout cela lui
met sur moi au cas le spectacle
rafraîchissant le glaçon pingouins
je paye coulter nitoo fait pas vous
allez le cas c'est peut-être une
allumette dans votre panpan jamais dans
les chapelles à l'uva sur moi c'est trop
dangereux on était libres du matin
aucune arme à feu sur moi on ne joue pas
avec ces choses-là on comment faire pour
aller pour des mots ce cas où il faudra
bien tout seul pourquoi veux-tu le faire
fort là un petit rond paris me dois de
croître alors tu n'as qu'à attendre le
dégel
un peu de patience titus je préfère les
trois banques
et après après c'est une autre histoire